[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right everyone should be able to
hear everyone fine
uh just to be on the safe side go ahead
and speak hustle let's make sure
everyone hears everyone
can i be heard clearly
if not please let me know i believe you
can
everyone oh my god
all right so
got it we've got a crazy show today
hustle
first off i want to thank people in the
chat only on xbox megatron what's up
megatron may you want a link to the show
man just hit me up man we got to get you
got to get you up on here i could see
you the link up right now i just have to
resize the boxes up but i could do that
on the go on the fly i could do that
easy
you nasty i see you in there and that's
mr hardy i i'm not sure how to pronounce
your first name kind sir but mr hardy i
see
is that ashley gamer retro nerd
good name by the way i see y'all thank
y'all for joining us man thank you all
for joining us for real all right so he
says that i'm a bit low is that a little
bit about better man i don't know some
some people ain't complaining you know
maybe we need to check your settings and
not my settings
you know i'm not able to hear like
through the zone thing because i guess
it gets to work like this cool a little
bit i'm not able to like even notice
that you're local you sound fine to me
yeah i i think i sound fine we'll see
man we'll see
first off
thank you for coming to the attic show
where we talk about the past present and
future of gaming got my co-host hustle
and motivate what's going on uh hustle
what you've been playing lately
oh okay so wait what i've been playing
a little bit uncharted been struggling
with that i've been playing been in my
super nintendo bag too and um i was
testing out um burnout revenge i didn't
stream it or anything but i've been
testing out burnout revenge to go along
with my retro tank
uh 5x but i think i'm going to say the
hell with it i'm gonna send my xbox off
to the castle stone age gamer that they
paid me to say it but i'm gonna send it
off to stone age gamer to get it modded
to have the hdmi out
you know i just want i want like the the
best like super best quality so i'm
gonna end up doing that but everything
has been good like i just been you know
running around um highly anticipating
horizon zero dawn too or horizon
forbidden west that's that's what's that
next week that's next week yeah that
drink dropped next week so i'm i'm
anticipating that
horizon
everyone else is hustle too low or is it
maybe just his settings like on my
settings you're in the yellow and i
don't really feel comfortable putting
you higher than the yellow so uh you
know we'll see a little bit more
feedback see exactly what we could do to
adjust everyone okay he's a little lower
all right
i'll go ahead and raise him a little bit
hey man i turned it up on the goddamn
apartment i turned it up on the day
going dbs
all right okay all right i'll follow
y'all all right so i turned it up i
turned him up how it is now
all right
so let's break this down all right first
things first too loud
first things first
wha what else you've been playing hustle
what else you know i've been in my retro
bag lately man um
the main thing right now is on child day
three i checked out i did have a chance
to check out um the uncharted what is
this
there you go i had a chance to play this
for a brief period of time just for a
little bit
um
i don't notice a difference graphically
but i'm playing on the performance mode
not the 4k mode because i had to play
this at 60 frames still is amazing
looking game i'm trying to lose legacy
is the game that i'm talking about if
y'all couldn't see it
um still looks amazing
it's just you know i'm getting back to
that so once i beat part three
we're on the part four and they'll be
onto my favorite
i i hear that man you know i've been
playing what's that game that everyone's
been playing the the fighting game
okay so i've been playing sifu uh
i've finally beat dying light which
we're going to talk about that briefly
and not necessarily the game we'll
probably talk about more about like the
bugs and the state games come in these
days because i feel like that's more
important than the actual game itself
like not to i enjoy dying light but i do
feel like it's one of those prime
examples where it's like come on guys we
need to do better on releasing games
that function correctly
uh so then we're going to talk about you
know had to have you played seafood
seifu ku jefu zebu like
i have not i have that only because i've
been you know i've just been
been in my retro bag but from what i
understand shifu was kind of like
somebody compared to sakura in terms of
his difficulty so you played it so i
kind of want your thoughts on it but if
it's anything like that and it has like
rogue elements hey listen i tried
returning when i put that thing right on
down dog that's not that's not my alley
though it's different i i actually can't
okay
you
you're look returnable is different
than seafood safe food jfu v food like i
don't know seafood we're gonna call it
seafood is that what's called seafood
yeah it's called seafood okay
seafood's a little bit different because
i feel like
we'll get to that we'll get to that
because we do have a whole topic related
to that because i i definitely want to
make sure that you know we go into that
correctly we got a five dollar super
chat from uh kendrick hardy probably
butchered your name but you know that
you know the deal by now you know the
deal throw platinum games trust in the
bushes
oh we're we
that's our finale our finale is talking
about platinum games i thought i was the
only one with some slander when it come
to platinum games like i'm glad that
people feel me in the comment section
man we can all
channel
our dislike for platinum games together
man i'm not saying that they make bad
games i'm saying they make games that
don't appeal to me but that's besides
the fact uh and you know we'll get to
that man we'll get to that but first
thing let's talk about hustle is i'm
sure you've seen
the reviews for dying like two dropped
and then the disgust for the bugs happen
right afterwards have you got a chance
to play dying light or at least see the
glitches and stuff that's happening with
dying light
um i saw a couple of the glitches um
those that type of first person game the
way it relies heavily on movement that's
not particularly for me um it's just
just not a thing of mine i didn't play
down like one when it comes to games
like that when it comes to those types
of games especially when it involves
movement i prefer third person hopefully
somebody on pc can throw a third-person
mod name so hustle can get have a good
go at it but i saw you know a lot of
discussion on it and um i i know you
told me you played it and you beat it i
really want to know like your thoughts
on everything did you did you enjoy it
did you like it did you hate it i want
to i want to know that version of it
first i want to before we like really
break this down so i i went into like a
huge rant on iop i'm not going to go too
much into that because i already said
that if you want that
logic over there listen to the iron
lords podcast
uh you know it's time stamped you know
first off let me let me back up a little
bit all right so i am officially
confirming
attic show will be on the iron lords
podcast spotify
uh all those little media stuff
uh people say ask for timestamps
i'm be real with you guys
you're asking a lot from me man you're
asking a lot so what i'm gonna do
because i didn't want to have a middle
ground there's no there's no realm where
i give you timestamps every podcast it's
just not happening but what i'm going to
try to do is i i am designing an overlay
right now i have been designing an
overlay so what i'm going to do is kind
of like you know the iron lords podcast
has like on the left they have like what
topic we're on i'ma try
to make it time based where i can give
you the time stamps in the podcast
itself now i have no
i have no clue how i'm gonna do it
it's it's gonna be a lot of trust and
air man you guys got to work with me i'm
a try so i'm thinking like i'm gonna put
like time stamps like on the top left
top right bottom left i don't know how
i'm gonna do it but i'm a try and we'll
see how it goes if not
gonna have to visualize you knowing the
timestamps skip around you know maybe
i'll
because what i do plan on doing
at the very least is i'm going to have
let me show you guys something real
quick because uh i do want to give them
a little bit
of
what i want to do so this is
this is how i'm probably going to set up
some stuff
and uh tell me how
the chat feels because there's we don't
really have a whole lot to talk about
today like be on the road uh yeah it's a
little light show it's all good yeah we
just working so this is
how
it will look if i
like do the separate windows because
normally i crop them together so i'll
crop them separately so let's say i make
this just a little bit smaller
and i make this just a little bit
smaller
all right so let me transition that now
if you look in the middle there's a
little bit of room in the middle now
what i want to do for you guys for the
round because it's not for me it's for
you
is i want to put in the middle i want to
put like an iron lord's podcast logo and
i might have that sucker glow for
different topics
so it'll glow the it you know it won't
glow for the beginning and end but it
will like it'll glow red for the first
topic glow gold for the second topic and
glow maybe green for the third topic and
that's that's pretty much how i'm gonna
do that
um i i
i'm going to start we got some stuff
that we're doing for iop right now so
i'm not really looking into it right now
but
probably here in the next month i'm
gonna have a new overlay and it's gonna
be multiple overlays
i'm gonna try to make this unique you
know obviously we're gonna have our our
basic
me and him just talking
and then what i'ma do
is you know everyone has like the
gameplay now i'ma be real with you guys
you ain't getting gameplay from me every
week it's just not happening
but
i'm willing to like do something like
this
and put the gameplay on the right make
it look all nice and fancy
and you know i'm willing to do something
like that but i'm going to put the
gameplay like right now we're talking
about dying light 2
uh in a minute we're going to talk about
dynalite 2. so i'll put dying light 2 in
the right part while we're talking and
then you know uh saifu seafood jefu in
the in the right part where we're
talking sifu and that that's how i'm
gonna go with that because uh and then
you know i'm gonna have one where we
have a guest because you know sometimes
we do have guests and i do want to make
sure that we give the guests uh their
flowers so we'll be definitely doing
that too
but
what
uh shout out to d nasty in the chat and
i was just thinking this as you were
talking we should do like i don't i
don't know if you watch a partner
interruption i'm not because i don't
know if you're a big sports guy but
typically with um
who's that michael wilbon and um tony
corner has what they do is they'll have
like a topic let's say we talk about
uh what's that what's this
sifu whatever say we're talking about
sifu
instead of a counter to cuba time stamp
what they do is they may talk about that
topic for about like five minutes or
maybe i'm in the 30 in the very
beginning i'm not saying that we should
do that for the timeline but i feel like
we should have like the set time
and then the time should count down like
that i was just thinking that too hey um
real quick i don't know did you see big
clouds requesting the chat
um
i saw this dude
attic over here sounding
that's all i saw did he like ask to come
on the shoulder
available you want to roll up i mean if
you want
i'm cool with it i i
we we we love when big cloud comes in
here because that's my boy he'd be
trying to come over here and act like he
he'd be saying these bars alone you
don't man you don't i'm sorry you don't
you but i will give you are the
playstation dude saying these bars
you're a reasonable playstation dude so
there's the link man get your
get yourself up in here
like look so that's how i plan on doing
it what i plan on doing too is when we
have like a big guest i plan on having
like their screen well not even big ass
i guess in general uh their screen's
gonna be bigger than ours
right uh we're gonna be on the top
they're gonna be on the bottom and we're
you know i've already reached out to
maddie play uh
spoiler alert he's supposed to come on
this week but uh he ended up he's not
feeling the greatest so definitely you
know send some love over to maddie play
we'll hopefully get him in here next
week if not we'll schedule something man
i'm going to get acg up in here i'm
going to get jeff grub i am going to
reach out to people like fame
entertainment i'm going to reach out to
uh k mega okay i'm going to get a little
bit like i i don't want to do it every
week because i want the show to be me
and hustle but i do think it's good if
we have
different perspectives a couple times a
month i don't know when we're gonna do
it
i gotta get the overlays done first man
like right now we are here looking mad
naked in these these overlay streets man
like look at this so so basic this is
literally just a black background with
me and him talking but you know what
i'm okay with that
shout out to the 97 yahoo who just upper
head just you know watching this rock um
yeah
yeah we got it yeah we got it you know
it's a work in progress we appreciate
y'all for joining us you know just each
and every week it's gonna work itself
out i promise you that i will promise
all right so let's go ahead and move our
way back to this dying light too thing
so we're to talk about
how state of games come in these days
huh so would you think it's uh it's fair
to say
that games are coming in more broken
than they ever have in the past
oh oh that's a big fact and
here's the thing see back in the day
right you can get it again and i'm gonna
refer to the no mercy um thing from me
because on no mercy back in the late 90s
i had to save glitch the way you can
play the game play the game play the
game and
for the first batch of those games that
came out they actually were broken so
you all the progress that you made
you couldn't really you couldn't fix it
it was nothing that you can do to fix it
i think it was something wrong with the
battery so did a big recall on it
that didn't make as much noise as
everything that we see now what we see
now like what was that what was that
what was the name of that game eric you
used to jump from world to what no man's
sky no man's sky was like the biggest
like offender coming out broken
unfinished
didn't live up to his full potential at
that time
that was real ugly dude took you know
the the owner he took y'all money and he
went on vacation he said i'm not gonna
tweet for a minute but i got my feet
kicked up you know looking through the
water and all that he said looking
through these the real blue water so now
like when we see everything now it's
like this used to happen back in the day
but the only difference was
everything wasn't as big we didn't have
platforms like this one to like voice
our opinion we didn't have a twitter
back in the day we had phones but one of
my own phones what's up sir you know
what's funny people keep saying like the
world got more sensitive the world's
always been the sensitive it's just it's
never been so
easily
to vote your opinion like like these
days you can literally go on
and tweet if you have a big enough
following you could tweet on 9 00 a.m
and have that company breaks broken
by like 3 p.m the next day like it's
it's crazy so you got big cloud gaming
in here man uh what's what's going on
what part of this show made you want to
come on here because there got to be
something i mean i mean there are
several parts i mean we got out of here
don't want to give you my props then we
got hustle being you know hustle or
looking like darth vader in his
background and she was definitely
i didn't stutter
excuse me because i hear one person i'd
be saying what i'm saying
and who's that on ilp that is that's two
we all been saying that nah nah you know
oh no you don't get in the flowers oh i
don't get no flowers
oh man
[Laughter]
what's up what's up though so so quite
same question to you
big cloud
do you feel like we're getting to the
point where maybe
the industry is grooming us more to
accept broken games at launch
i mean we're now seeing more service
games coming to the player right so
and people are acceptable of that
so
it's possible but yeah i can definitely
i see it um these fixa later games
that's why i dubbed them uh we'll
definitely see more of them in this case
i mean halo infinite we're still waiting
on the other content that's going to
drop well when was that supposed to drop
this year it was supposed to they said
well they said they're supposed to get a
road map or something
yeah something like that yeah you're
still you're still missing
your your content there so you know that
already kind of sets the tone for other
games and other companies like god
forbid if the next destiny
does do that type of route right where
it launched less features than the last
one
and you're just waiting for upon months
for
content
so
in a weird way i would say yes because
the market's kind of shifting towards
that way where they want to have these
games that just live
you know longer than just or in terms of
playability they want them to live
longer than just two years or a year and
a half vice versa so yeah it's
definitely possible i feel like
we've always had some form of live
service games in multiplayer when it
comes to dlc long-term commitments on
the game you know i could name halo i
mean in some ways you could say the
uncharted games or some form of lives as
a service it's just now
games like destiny games like fortnight
like they've showed that you can fund an
entire game off of these practices and i
don't think that we should do everything
i've always been
when it comes to games as a service i
want games as a service to be
implemented in games that make sense i
don't want them forcing it
uh like would you be more acceptable of
gta 6 if it went that route
i mean
at this point gta
already is a games as a surface like
they didn't really they didn't upgrade
anything on the campaign
uh they they focused entirely on the
single player if anything gta 6 was a
multiplayer game that they gave you a
good great single player campaign
um but what if they treat the single
player like that like they kind of
experimented with the franklin
like you know tell me like they give you
they give you majority of the story but
then like they'll give you other acts
a part of it you know i mean they're
substantial to it and they'll add upon
that over the uh the months
type of thing
personally the way like if you look at
the the report i don't know if i saw how
much they sold on gta it's only 160
million
bro and they're getting ready to launch
this joint again on ps5 and series x so
wherever you go gta is always in the top
10 right now this sucker sells another
40 million that's 200 million
copies of a game that's been what nine
years old now at this point and they're
going to charge you this at full price
again
and they're you know teasing you saying
we just now started production on our
new ones like no
so
i mean well i'll just say i'll say this
in regards to what you were saying big
cloud i don't think that they'll do that
again because i don't think that the fan
base will let them get away with that
yeah i know that i know they did i don't
know what about
numbers and they even put the franklin
um
story expansion quote unquote the dr dre
expansion they put it online i don't
think they i don't think their fan base
let that let that right again i think
these are
i mean gta i don't know man i mean it's
not nintendo right they're not nintendo
obviously they got a standard and people
hold them accountable but
i don't know man people have been very
like they're easily going to get away
with that yeah
there's more people playing that
multiplayer than played that campaign by
far probably like three to one by far so
what if they did a reverse addict what
if they gave you the multiplayer first
of gta 6 and then the story came later
oh no
i don't think i don't think they would
do that because they're not known for
doing stuff like that and i think that
they're one of the companies that their
reputation hasn't really been tarnished
too much
so i don't think that they would risk
their reputation but i i would still
play it uh because um i really enjoyed
gta online i think it got a little crazy
there towards you know the end of i was
playing it but i enjoy the concept of it
it's just it is one of those things
where they want you to put more time in
that game than i put in destiny
yeah they they lost me with the business
side you know someone when you buy like
your own little empire and like you
invest into like the i guess the stock
market type of thing they were trying to
build upon it's like okay we're gamers
we're not
trying to go to the moon here but i just
learned how they try to do they even did
the story like that you have to like uh
invest all your money into the stock and
then become a billionaire and you know
you use the stock market like
so i don't know it's just it's going to
determine
how exactly much time they have we don't
know how much time they have at the
moment um
i i'm just curious to see exactly
what is going to be done with the bugs
in the syst like
in the gaming industry i was
really happy to see cyberpunk treated
the way it was
as much as
no because i i like that playstation i
said
regardless the playstation donut for
their own motives they didn't want to
keep
refunding games i was loving the fact
that playstation's like look your stuff
is so broken we got to pull it
and i kind of wish that would be done
for the majority thing like look i'm not
saying if you got minor issues when a
game launches like some server issues
that's different there's not a lot of
highlights yeah there's not a lot of
things you could do when it comes to
server issues but if your game is
legitly broken and there's multiple game
breaking bugs and it's not functioning
correctly there's like there's massive
marketing that was done that what that
isn't present in the game i want steam
to pull that [ __ ] i want
i want xbox to pull that i want
playstation to pull that i want epic
game store to pull that because i want
the the
the i want every big store owner to put
their foot down and say if you launch
broken we will cost you millions of
dollars
as they should though um yeah that that
cyber well i know we know we're talking
about like different bugs in different
games um and we're going back to um
dying light in a minute but i remember
like cyberpunk i remember when the night
that joint dropped and nobody knew how
messed up it was
i mean i think people had thoughts but
nobody everybody got no chairs yeah yo
everybody was oh my god yeah
it was just the thing that was like all
right maybe it's some bugs here and
there it turned out it's so bad that
that game isn't fully fixed as of today
it's still not fully fixed and the game
came out what two years ago now so that
still winning that ps5 release that's
that's the whole thing
ain't nobody waiting on that jordan i
think um
i think they better get back to gwent
get back to the card game and they
better get back to the witcher full
it might be it definitely might be a rap
but not attitude you're there right you
know and i laughed in the beginning when
you know you was talking about cyberpunk
i just laughed because it was just funny
as hell that you came out and said it
but you know they they really got to put
their foot down because you you allowing
broken products on your on your platform
at that point if i'm a casual and i
don't know no better like
i just say i don't know nobody say i
bought that game for my little nephew
who really wanted to play it hey this
ain't working but he don't know why it's
not working he thinks he might think
it's steam or something but he thinks
it's not working so yeah that's that's
the thing that could really cause um
cause trouble on your end but people now
want to go back to your storefront so
that's you know it's
yeah i mean some you know playstation
was the first one that they bossed up
they said now we're not allowing this
and um i think as of recently it just
came back to the playstation storefront
um big cloud i want you to correct me if
i'm wrong on that i want to say i read
something i could be wrong somebody
probably didn't it probably did because
i think some patches that dropped for
the game so it probably is on the
storefront again maybe so i'm not sure
just to clarify what would you guys
consider broken games that should have
been pulled off the store
a cyberpunk
sponsor
i think that's pretty much i think
i think master chief collection should
have got up out of there uh i think
battlefield i think battlefield 4 should
have got up out of there
um oh i missed that one
yeah what else it's a lot of games that
didn't launch uh okay what about games
that launch functioning but
they completely lied to their consumer
base about what's in the game like no
man scott
was out writers one of those writers
yeah
yeah
do you think that
games like no man's sky that lied
massive lied to the marketing nothing
they're sayings in the game obviously
they turn that around it's working now
uh it's it's functioning it has a lot of
the original features that they promised
in the game but at the time none of that
was in the game do you think those type
of games should be pulled as well like
that it's like look like
and i'm not saying that you just
oh i promised you
a certain feature and it's not there
but i'm saying like i promised you
serious
features that's not in the game like
co-op
uh you know stuff like that do you think
those should be pulled
um no man's sky it would have it would
have hit different if you would have
said it was more of an ambitious
for what we wanted to do down the road
that would have been better because then
he would have been like yeah we got most
of you know i mean um
i get what they were trying to do with
that but personally no man it kind of
redeemed itself for a little bit so i
would say no sky is okay but it took a
minute you know i mean marketing was
definitely uh not right there but there
are a lot of games that have these crazy
like somebody's posting the chat
christopher that's true aliens colonial
marines
yeah um follow you know
and shout out to um todd howard over
there over there bethesda he said yo
when that drink came out broke first
people hit hit up with xbox was like yo
how we fix this
like when stuff like that happen yo you
just gotta delay your game though like
look i don't know how much money it
costs to the leg game i don't know how
much money it costs to like put a patch
in the game because we a lot of games we
see they get like day one patches and
all that
i don't know how much how much bread
that costs but you gotta believe when
they especially when you got like a
games as a service and stuff like that
you got to believe that you're gonna
make that money back so even if you got
to push it out just like maybe a month
or two or inside the case somebody
should have just delayed that joint oh
cyberpunk they should have delayed
cyberpunk should have delayed what they
was doing um but when you when you run
across these problems and you know those
problems are there like yo don't play
yourself look sometimes you gotta be
like hey look this ain't working the way
that they should and we can't put a
band-aid over a bullet won't so like nah
because your reputation is on the line
and that's the other thing and i do want
to go like the cg project red for a
minute
yo brother the way that they they amped
up cyberpunk and like you got to live
with that now well the thing about
cyberpunk so this is where i got to take
a little bit of well not fault right but
i got to take a little bit of uh heat
off them the community overhyped it so
i'm saying they were holding them to
like the witch
by the way yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the
witcher like everybody that was like the
main thing they was like oh you guys
don't think it's going to be this great
because which is good this time the
third episode going
we haven't even seen the game half the
stuff they talking about they were
moving stealthily you know ivy dude was
like oh man it's going to be better you
know what you're talking about this
stuff's here third-person cut scenes are
here the damn game comes out were there
any third-person cutscenes i'm like dude
stop y'all looking silly right now it
didn't
then we get to the glitches you know
it's like no but i don't think anybody
don't get me wrong everybody has a bias
everybody has like a specific you know
preference or whatnot sure but let's
keep it a buck whenever a game that you
know damn well when they told you flat
out on paper was going to be there the
moment they started ripping out core
features
and you get the halo into this when they
said the co-op's not there right any
game that rips out or any studio that
works out core features from any game
it's like bro
you have to really start looking at that
different from what you see big cloud
though i'd rather take a halo infinite
situation because at least when that
multiplayer it worked it it worked well
and it worked well by the way even
though there's a lot of game modes what
was the biggest thing
what was the big thing you were hyped
for cyberpunk right aside from the world
you hyped for that third person
customization it was the college you're
supposed to customize a lot of that
all that stuff got cut and dude's like
well you can look in mirrors around the
world are you really gonna be looking
around looking for damn convenient
mirrors to look at your character no
you're not doing that it's just the one
mirror in the apartment and like yeah i
wouldn't like
that no more yeah i feel like man i feel
that though like wrong some games are
cool with first person they work
but sometimes a third person perspective
can really amplify a game i think
cyberpunk would have been better if it
launched better obviously but it was in
third person i think we would appreciate
it more especially when we first saw
that first showcase when he jumped in
the car he drove off it's like it hit
different now because the first person
like yeah it all looks the same i think
i think my issue with where things are
right now with the industry
is just
how accepting people are
like you know
instead of
attacking it's kind of like the console
or stuff instead of
yo battlefield 2042 ain't it you don't
buy that let them fix their stuff then
buy it
people are like give them time give them
time for what
you know like explain to me give them
time for what
they didn't have no problem taking my
money at all
so why should i give them time to to get
they stay stuff together look it's
different if you bought the game and
he's like yo it's kind of messed up but
it is what it is i'll wait for it right
but you know
you know you just i'm awake but it's
another thing when you're on twitter
telling other people not to be upset
because just because you ain't upset
does not give you the reason the the
right the audacity to say that i'm upset
i'd be upset whatever i want to be upset
with and if i paid 60 70 on playstation
for a game that does not work return oh
and you tell me not to voice my opinion
on the matter guess what you're getting
muted
because at that point it's like look we
got to be vocal because if we're not
vocal and we don't start really coming
down on these developers and publishers
for launching broken games it's not
getting better it's going to get worse
you know another thing that's kind of
telling too it was that game uh it was
anthem remember anthem mm-hmm
yeah actually we got to find out from
kendrick hardy anthem was all around a
failure content functions and that was
actually in the game the downgrade geez
yeah i agree with you man anthem and
what's funny is
i was on the anthem hate train i know
you
were
and funny funny is
your boy never left the anthem hate
train i've never booted up anthem
besides the demo um i want to point out
that that the attic was right uh you
could come at me you can attack me it
doesn't matter because at the end of the
day
i was right that game came out and it
didn't hit the way it was and destiny my
mistress is still alive
so you know
we we gotta we gotta find out soup trap
from uh from dieback uh hold up mike
the doctor the doctor the doctor like
there's like something on my screen a
little bit so i couldn't say the doctor
sixty-three it wasn't easy
brother addict is preaching
as i look like that's my only thing it's
like i just don't want it to be a
standard that's all like i don't mind if
some games depending on even games like
like cyberpunk games like bethesda makes
as long as i can realistically
understand why your game came out a
little buggy i cannot i can get down
with that but if your game comes out and
it's not playable it's not buggy it's
not playable it's different is it
it was so bad they skipped a year and
they're coming back this year oh yeah
it's 20 years yeah bro you know what's
funny you know i'm glad you mentioned it
did you see the gameplay for the second
one that joy looked horrible it looked
uninspired like what did you learn you
didn't learn anything you haven't seen
that much gameplay up to this point
i'm like bro atw and uke's about to slap
y'all back to reality with it when they
drop days i cannot wait
i can't wait to take the crown back and
there there's a big issue too that i you
know i pulled on uh
on iop that i'm not saying every
publisher out there does it but i do
feel like sometimes
um
you know article writers review writers
people that write on media sites i feel
like occasionally if your game isn't
high caliber like that cyberpunk that
that call of duty status that that that
huge caliber publisher that has all
these games and your game just has one
good game i do feel like sometimes the
the reviewer will be a little bit more
hard it's like look i just ignored all
the nonsense that happened on cyberpunk
a couple years ago i ignored all that
stuff but guess what
i'm i'm a i'm gonna put a magnifying
glass on dying light too i'm gonna tell
you every issue i have but i'm gonna
give i'm gonna give uh i'm gonna give
anthem i don't think anthem got a nine
out of ten or anything but i'm gonna
give cyberpunk a nine out of ten
remember that fiasco thing that happened
better get solid five with the
concentration camps pretty much where
they flew you out to the place and made
you review it there
hey y'all got it
that's oh
oh my god oh baby see that many risking
games now y'all notice that like
everybody has to like tone down and like
give you a certain product like it's not
like everybody's going ambitious with
stuff
just not doing it
i mean this guy can't be too brutal
games can't beat two you know i mean
they just can't they just can't have
their concealer they have to go to it
it's sad you know we're better they're
very creative we're about to get to uh
uh saifu uh sifu you played that right
big cloud
cypher what's safe whatever
g for you i don't care we got a five
dollar super shot from kendrick hardy no
time given battlefield three and one and
five 1.5 years before it's played
playable why keep pre-ordering so dumb
all right all right let let me hone in
on that super chat for one brief moment
i agree
these games shouldn't come out and they
should be playable not 1.5 years after
they come out but at the same time
i can never blame the person
pre-ordering the game
they're excited for the product they
want to get the product there's a lot of
uh pre-order stuff that goes into the
product sure sometimes you get that
stuff after the game comes out but if
you're just going to get it why not
why even white at that point and i
understand that the pre-ordering scene
gives developers and publishers we're
going to make this money so we can do
whatever we want but at the end of the
day we should never blame the consumers
for spending their money should blame
the people that's providing the product
that doesn't work
all right let me i want to um respond
shout out to a lady fox fire here in the
chat um she said she was very
disappointed with the division gears 5
and anthem and i'm going to stop it
right there battlefield uh 2042 hey yo
if you paid for that yo shout out to you
for that because you got it but no but
the gears 5 thing that that's going to
hit hit my heart a little bit too i
wasn't against dude up until that point
i started with gears 5. and that was
like the first time i saw a game go up
and then go down they go up and go oh my
god i'm going to have to hit erica
because i have a ball and chat about you
oh no that's cool
real quick from kendrick hardy
addict we called that during the ea live
demo of anthem we was all there we felt
it was a failure leaving the demo and we
couldn't play i agree with you i
definitely agree with you and it's like
i said i don't want to not i my thing is
i want to point to to take the spotlight
off to people pre-ordering the game and
i want to put all the spotlights on the
developer and publisher i don't want
none of the spotlight because to me
kendrick i feel like it's one of those
things where if we start and i'm not
saying you were doing i'm saying i i see
that a lot on twitter you know don't
pre-order a game until it comes out but
to me
that's just diverting the blame to
someone else like we need at the end of
the day
we're we're consumers we buy [ __ ] that's
what we do and that's why my mindset is
we should never blame the people
spending the money sure you could call
us dumb for spending money i'm down for
that you call me an idiot all you want
you can sit there you can hashtag attic
don't buy that [ __ ] i'm gonna be like i
still bought that [ __ ] so you know like
i get that we gotta follow superchat
from christopher
jesser
jetzer
i guess
dying light 2 had a lot of uh cut
content from the original e3 trailer
however i'm having fun with it on pc but
i didn't realize how much it changed
yeah i will say some of those um did you
guys see those
those downgraded things
yeah no
they were pretty significant awesome
pretty significant um
they improved on a lot though they
improved on a lot at the same time it
does like a lot of the the the heart
i don't know if you feel like that it
kind of just been cut a little bit from
this game like it's like yeah
i i i do like it's not bad but it feels
like you lost a little
ambition
and part of me part of me gets on my
nerves on that too because it's like why
put that energy out there and try to act
like you can meet it
like yeah ubisoft stop doing that show
us what the game looks like at launch
you can even have a little bit of a
downgrade something that we have to get
digital foundry to show us a downgrade
so like you know
famous thing was the the puddle gate
from spider-man people attacked attacked
attack there's all this this is this
this is something to do with the day and
night cycle no it's not that particular
scene was high definite they really put
a lot of detail into that because that
was what they was promoting the game
with at the time it but and people like
oh that's that's not what happened at
like if you took that scene and the
artistic
change
from that scene and you put that across
the whole game it was definitely
downgrading now did that mean the game
was worse than it was no the game was
still good to you guys i think it was
average as hell but you know it is what
it is
i just want the energy took it off the
people that's calling the people out
you should have looked at the insomniacs
you should look at the tech lands you
should look at the eas and say we don't
like this now downgrading is different
because i do think that that's a
marketing thing i don't think we're
getting rid of that i think it's it's
sleazy uh i don't know about that after
after to watch those things i don't
never want to hear that
the thing is though
is
the watchdogs thing was bad
but we still getting downgraded looking
gay it was anthem though so was anthem
though we saw and but anthem was still
the thing is
ain't no anthem hold up let me let me
talk anthony was definitely downgraded
but you could still see it looked a nice
good game now i'm not saying dang light
too don't look good but there is some
things where i'm just like i'm looking
at it it looks like really it looks like
you know those like that old gears of
warship effect that they would put on it
to make everything look like really like
gray and gray and green i feel like a
lot of dying light has that there's not
like a lot of colors like yo
that's why purple when you see the uv
lights just pops out so well because
everything else about the game is great
spider-man miles morales was the best
spider-man was better than spider-man
2016
by a long shot
18 whatever man
the reason i thought it was the 2016 is
because it was 2016 game
before we move on before we move on um
rrd and
what's up carlos alvarado hey guest 5
was fun for me but we're not going to
sit up here act like it wasn't broken
that launch but we're not going to sit
up here and act like that game didn't
have this
abs and flows peaks and valleys whatever
yeah
see right here
here's the thing
here's the thing with gears
gears wasn't broken at launch the
servers were broken at launch because
when me and smooth i don't know why they
put the single player attached to the
service that was the dumbest thing i've
ever seen because me and smooth played
it literally the night before it went
public and we woke up to finish it and
we couldn't get into a game like it's
it's and that hurt like and that's
another thing you know we've completely
went
way into a circle
that's fine we got
got five dollars come back for kitchen
i pre-ordered i'm saying pre-ordering
after they've repeated failures is dumb
let me clarify i'm just saying you have
to make rebuild the trust i agree with
you uh but even at that point i still
will say if i
buy every final fantasy game after
they've let me down for 10 years
15 years 20 years 25 years
you easily could call me dumb i will
accept that you know i might get like a
dumb uh beanie with dumb players across
across the top and wear that when i'm
being real with something but at the end
of the day i completely understand that
and i value and i appreciate that kind
of standpoint but i do think even if i'm
being dumb which i've been dumb a lot
with buying games
it's still my money it's not my job to
make sure that product comes out and
works right it's their job to make sure
that product comes out and works right
now i've always been one of those people
when it comes to to standing together
with people and make sure stuff works
i've always been one of those people
that if there's enough of a movement i'm
down i'm there like the battlefront 2
i'm down i'm there like i got to feel
like me standing
against the trend is going to work
because
i'll be real with you guys we're not the
we're not the casual consumer the casual
consumer is what spends the majority of
this money into the market
so my standpoint is unless i see a lot
of the media jumping on a lot of the
influencers kind of like we're seeing
with nfts
yeah you know unless i see a huge stash
stature of people standing against
something
i'ma fall back
because because i i ain't getting a
target put on my head for nothing it's
got to come in and it's like
nintendo just started their own didn't
they got pass
oh oh boy oh boy well you know what's
funny is my brother he was like why
isn't iop made it so nft is like look
i was like i was like i was like zachary
i was like the gaming industry is
fighting back on nft so i was like we
would get cancelled which i don't agree
with nfts i would never even suggest it
in the first place but i was like if we
did nfts iop would get canceled the next
damn day like
who's um he's a voice actor i cannot
think of his name baker baker yes he has
the nft and
he uh turned it down he's not doing them
he literally reversed and said apology
afterwards he was like i'm sorry for
those who were vocal that i labeled his
trolls i'm sort of going troy now you
know what he means you don't shoot
aka
i'm about to lose all the good
credibility i've built up
there's about to get my man all the way
out there like
do you do when you see stuff like that
golf club for real do you when you see
stuff like that do you do you feel
like we should we we should support them
less because we feel like they're
disgenuine or
look
i'm not even mad at nobody for making
any money though like i think i'm more
mad at the fact that he kind of backed
down i think i think i would have had
more respect if the man came out and
said look
they was offering me a bag
but i clearly see you guys
don't want that happening and i respect
the opinions of my followers
over this type of bag and then he puts
that thing he's like but guys they were
offering me a big bag like
yeah i mean you know but you know what
they'll say all money ain't good money
in particular hey listen man if you
don't know
of course it does but if y'all know
where the nft is i saw a video on it and
i can't i think i came out more confused
afterwards i'm like yo bruh now i'm good
that's and i don't really want nothing
to do with that but um you know
everybody like i don't know we not
talking about
but imagine me doing imagine me doing an
nft just like a picture like this
i don't know who i was talking to i said
i said this is this nft right here
right i give you right now for 5.99
[Laughter]
and if you guys really feeling me man
you don't like the xbox i got you
but this one here this one here is six
is is 15.99 because of the 10
playstation tax
i mean
yeah i mean but you know a lot of the
you know and i do want to bring it back
to you know
the very first topic that we were
talking about somebody down like too hey
man look
we pre-or i pre-order games just because
i want to hurry and buy it and get it
out the way so i want to worry about it
later whether i get it on pc or get it
on console yeah sometimes you gotta yeah
sometimes you know you take the wins
with the losses sometimes sometimes you
know it might come out perfect a lot
uncharted you know i'm being biased of
course but other times it might not so i
mean just it's just a chance you're
taking plus like if you know you're
gonna play it and you know you're gonna
get an end like that
you might as well just pay it right now
like you're not even thinking about it
so when the joint you know go go up for
preload then that's typically what i do
and i have very fast in that but when
the game does go up for freeload i
already got it so by the time i get home
from work i don't got to worry about
that portion of it either somebody said
there's a bunch of different reasons why
we pre-order um i'm actually sorry to
hear a lot of the things about downlight
too because i saw a few other reviews on
it a lot of people they it's like up and
down positive and negative but it's just
it should be ironed out in a couple
weeks but it's sad that you know
unfortunately that they have it um now
i don't see them lasting for that long
but the big glitches are what not i mean
at the end of the day
you know
i just want the industry to improve and
i don't feel like
i know a lot the majority of these devs
don't want the games coming i know
there's a reason the majority of this
happens is because publishers push for
uh you know they want to get it before
the next financial quarter et cetera et
cetera and some of this has worked out
for some publishers and developers but
you know
there's a chance it doesn't and with
like cd projekt red
if you went back and asked them do you
want to delay this another year or
coming up i'm pretty sure every single
person in that office including the
people that pushed it out it's gonna say
let's delay this a year because they
didn't it didn't work out well for them
like it really hurt their company as a
whole
i think the government had something to
do with that though um yeah
the polish government had something to
really
say about what was going on over there
so
that's why i kind of don't i don't
particularly i know we was kind of
crapping on them earlier but you know
and rightfully so but
that that they were their hand was
forced a little bit so i know i don't
want people to like to forget that
either we know it was like a super bad
experience
and everything but but that government
kind of
on the yeah bright side addict we did
have one game that had a super smooth
lunch you think about
house i'm playing yu-gi-oh
and i'm feeling myself because i'm
winning over and over again but then i
start playing people that actually know
how to play
then i started losing over and over
again um five dollar super down to
kendrick hardy make your money let
people be suckers like addicts and
pre-orders i am i'm really bad with
pre-orders and and i like i really am
like i think the only person i know
that's worse than me is kid smooth kiss
me will buy anything anything
it doesn't matter what it is he's gotten
a little bit better throughout the years
that's why it's so amazing to share
there's a library with kid smooth
because when i attempt to to buy it
he's already bought it but you know
since me and him both come up as content
creators we get the majority of the
games through review codes these days so
we don't have to really worry about that
but man there was a time where i was
buying a game every week
and i'm glad to say
that time is over
but you know let's let's let's move on
to the game we just recently bought it's
called saifu seafood g-few
sifu
sifu all right so i'm assuming a lot of
you
ha a lot of you in the chat have played
it i'm kind of curious here's your
opinion put it in the i
have not talked to you guys in the chat
you know tell me how you guys feel about
it
and
uh
hold up it says saifu i just it's a spy
fool it's seafood like seafood like
seafood yes yes but sifu
[Laughter]
look i
i will say it however i want all right
so let's talk about seafood let's talk
about shaq
so oh no
sifu
let's talk about seafood sifu is a game
that's came out
and it's kind of like
it's like a corridor beat em up where
you go from one room to another um
i like the way that they've handled
stuff and i like the way that they
haven't handled stuff i think it's a
really unique concept i do think that
the controls are a little janky and i
feel like i i'm not control over my
character sometimes like sometimes if
someone comes too close to me i'll be
beating someone up and i'll be about to
finish him and then this dude gets too
close to me and my character's like
i'll come back to you later i'm fighting
you now like
and i don't like that like there's not
like a lock on button uh and i'm really
annoyed with that because i feel like if
you're having multiple characters around
you there needs to be a lockdown button
where i can focus on one person at a
time because i feel like
this can this game is difficult but it's
it's harder because
of
the
the conditions that the controller
scheme gives you like
and i really enjoyed it i got to the
second boss my first go
and there's only five but what i really
enjoy about the game is just
how fluid the controls feel when they
work
but when they don't work
man it's annoying a lot of you sitting
there like thinking i'm about to win
and then all of a sudden
i'm fighting this big dude over here now
and i like so i've learned that you have
to like dash towards them
because i think it goes off like uh the
like kind of like an aoe thing where if
they come into a certain diameter around
you you're you're naturally going to
like lean towards them you know what i'm
saying yeah and sometimes it does happen
randomly and you know i know neither one
of you play i don't think hustle you
played it have you
no i haven't but i do have a couple
questions okay um so i was listening to
weapon wheel this past sunday and bg had
kind of went into his whole
thing about it so apparently this is
more like mortal kombat and what i mean
by that is like in order to block you
first off you don't use the directional
pad to play this game use the analog
stick right at it
yes the analog stick
how about this like this is more like i
will agree
sometimes
it's weird you have to block up and
block down which to me well you could
you could do a general block but when
someone comes out with like a like a
weapon you're going to want to you're
going to want to like like kind of like
sleep to the side like you you you don't
want to just block because if people hit
you with like pose and stuff they're
going to get through that block pretty
fast that's why they give you that guard
that's why they like if they're swinging
uh some kind of weapon at you you can
like strive to the to the back a little
bit and just miss it entirely you're not
blocking it it's not hitting you and you
could do the counter attack immediately
and and i i really enjoy the game but
it's like i said the only issue i have
another issue where this is one of the
the most unique
mechanics that i've ever seen in gaming
where it's like if you die you age
and you get wiser with defeat basically
that's what they're saying well
the more times you age the stronger you
get but the the less health you have so
you could do a lot more damage when
you're in your 70s but you get hit like
once or twice and it's a wrap
so
what i
what i would appreciate it on here is a
little bit more of a cinematic approach
now i know it's probably because of
budget concerns and stuff like that but
at the end of the day the budget of the
game is not my concern i'm still going
to give my opinion i'm still going to
talk my [ __ ] so so you wanted more of a
return approach like when you die no
like you know you like the scenario kind
of but like
like when you get killed and you fall to
your death i wanted there to be like one
of those things where it zooms out and
it's like did you guys like and i don't
know if you guys seen for the people
that's seen the witch queen uh
dlc trailer it showed the hive being
regenerated from the from the light i
wanted to see more of that where you
know you're on the ground you're messed
up and you see yourself aging
while you're waking up you know what i'm
saying
like and i don't think that they did
that well enough and they don't really
really they don't explain a whole lot of
why you have this ability either
so i'm just like i get what it is it's
kind of like you know a beat em up where
you have five levels the point is to get
through the levels as easy and
efficiently as possible and keep that
that young age
because
you have to go through five levels
without dying of old age and that might
seem easy to the people watching the
chat
but
all it takes is like dodging the wrong
way and you've lost a couple years and
how the aging mechanic works is let's
say i start i die
get like one death counter uh you have
these things i call them the goku
characters because i like gold yellow or
something like that so if you beat like
key characters or or these these goku
characters
um it lowers that counter so let's say i
die three times i have three counters
but then i kill goku character it goes
down to two
so now when i die i age two years
or it'll be three years because when you
die you gain one you age three years
so the more you die the more you're
gonna age so let's say that you do
really good you only die one time in the
in the first place when you get to the
second place you're gonna have a age
encounter of zero and when you die
you're only gonna age one time because
you had zero and you you just get that
one from the death and i think that's i
think it's a unique thing and i honestly
think that
someone needs to buy this studio because
this
this
kind of concept
is so unique
and regardless
regardless if they didn't have the funds
to properly do this
i want to see a sifu saifu jefu i want
to see a second one that has the correct
funding and you see
like and keep in mind like
how the game's about revenge you're
you're going after the people
that did wrong by you at the beginning
of the game so
and when you come across these
individuals there's five of them
obviously five levels five uh people
all it really is is you walk in he looks
at you you look at him and they might as
well have the mortal kombat and now it's
just saying fight like
there's really no cinematics explaining
like this emotion there's no dialogue
yeah there's no real emotion between you
and them and there might be some emotion
with some of the hiring characters like
the person who actually did the wrong
uh because the first people you're
fighting now is pretty much the person
the person that did the wrongs lackeys
it's his friends you know what i'm
saying yeah so yeah so that's all i
wanted and and look this game's a great
game and i honestly feel like
there's a lot of people that need to
pick this game up i think it's like 40
dollars if you don't get the deluxe
edition so it's 40 dollars right now and
it's made by a company named uh slow
clap and almost says slo-mo but it's
made by uh slow clap these are the same
people who made up zalba and i was just
like looking at the trailer just now
um the combat does seem very very
similar um from just looking at this
trailer how is
why i go say it's a lot of one-on-ones
because i've seen people get jumped in
this that in the third but it's like
it's kind of somebody compared it to
sakura on twitter so if y'all it's a
little bit it's similar it is similar
yeah so so i i when they when they said
that when they but i will say sakura is
better balanced but sacro is better
balanced yeah it comes down to your
posture wanna say this well well i'm
gonna say this when they said sakurai
would scare me the hell away from me i
got that joint on pc i don't wanna smoke
a second let me be the first to tell you
that but um but a lot of like we saw i
don't know if y'all saw it but somebody
beat this game in like two hours
somebody somebody ran i could totally
see that because i beat the first level
in like 15 minutes 15 20 minutes like
you're gonna get timed in this game
because of the amount of dying that you
do i'm pretty good at seeing patterns
but when you put me in a kung fu game
apparently i'm i i'm a virgin in this
level man i don't know what the hell's
going on
like i'm sitting here i got a question
what
well how's the music how's the music's
good
it's it's okay i wouldn't like say it's
anything special keep in mind probably
like cognito and king david and solve
this is they stuff stuff like this is
what they grew up on they probably like
the soundtrack more than i do i just
think it's cool like it's something like
special we got a five dollar super chat
from 706 gamer
saifu soul fujofu jefu stole the age
mechanics and sifu from a gang called
chrono before the ashes
i don't know about that i don't know i
didn't play that game if they stole it
then they stole it y'all gotta chop it
up let me look that up right quick i do
want to say this this game makes me miss
one particular game and i hope we get a
sequel for it
y'all played it sleeping dogs sleeping
dogs
you know what i actually thought it's
the grown-up grand i thought there you
go
i was thinking because i'm gonna make a
video here soon and i was thinking about
like
games that people can bring forward and
really invest into them and i was
thinking if someone like sony microsoft
and probably microsoft because microsoft
needs to
invest more to that third person
genre if they bought
you know sleeping dogs and they like
like the initiative or someone really
expert at at third person maybe not the
initiative because they're making a
first person which i don't know why they
did that but we're not going to get into
that it's completely off off the radar
but if they would really invest into
that and give that a proper budget give
that a lot a lot of you know time to to
really cook i think that could compete
with something like an uncharted
it's just you gotta because if you think
about it
first off
if you really
let my god
shout out to 706 gamer he no he right
he's right they did get this idea from
um the game that he mentioned chronos
before the ashes
i'm looking at it now my fault
yo that wow that's that's why
well you can be inspired by somebody and
and improve on that a lot of these
companies take his inspiration from one
another in one aspect or another that's
the polite way to say we stole we're
going but there you go
i'm upset that there ain't more stilling
going around in this industry like why i
said that
that's what i'm saying that's what i was
about to say why hasn't no one stole the
nemesis system let's be honest here chat
tell me why they can't take that damn
system i'm sorry why is it something
like star renegade a small indie
developer is making something like the
nemeziz system but no other developer
has took in that it is beyond crazy to
me
it is what it is i'm not going to say
that you need to jack their stuff
obviously make it your own don't just
jack exactly what they do make it make
sense but why has no one took that damn
system i will say this man if uh sony
acquires
uh square enix you could see us sleeping
dogs too
you know when y'all when you say
sleeping dogs like what that puts me
what the my friend had put me in is like
that's direct competition for
a grand theft auto somebody in the track
chad mentioned a true chara two crimes
as well
yeah it was that that joined on the
right i liked l.a street was my favorite
snoop dogg you could play new
you could play a snoop dogg for sure and
it was it didn't have to be as realistic
but i remember having that game on the
og xbox that game was super fun but yeah
yeah no end up but i just took a look at
shout out with 706.
when he said that i like damn
they really did take that but you know
it's all good
you know shout out to slo clap man um
hopefully they should be so quiet though
i think somebody needs to go pick them
up if they can so
one of you want to read this
individual's name
i got a five dollar trooper from
uh sifo pedic excuse me cfo poetic ex
initiative sifo poetic x initiative if
you if we butchered that i'm gonna have
to
you're gonna have to look in the mirror
and blame yourself for making that name
all right i got it right
what's funny is is soft says it crazy
nice but i'm not solved so you're gonna
have to
we got uh at slow clap should join uh
someone else i'm sure it's another
developer in making the wong oh it's
probably the people
the wu-tang came uh so slow cap has been
honing their engine since the first game
i i agree
but i want them to stay
separate because i feel like both of
them can make solid experiences
but i am on this more thing where i do
feel like
sifu
sony needs to acquire that studio
because
that studio
cries
their classic
nurturing
this studio needs nurturing this studio
needs funds to be ran through it if
you're going to actually bet on
something bet on this studio
um and i feel like especially where like
sony's kind of backed away from like the
j the the asian culture in their games
i feel like this would be a good way
stepping back into it uh we got a two
dollar street drive from big cloud game
we are too old our eyes aren't what they
used to be
look man
it is
initiative did i get your name right
though that's what i'm asking i wonder
if i got it right i'm just curious i'm
just curious but
now this
so
all right
we got the main event the main event of
the evening
platinumgames
wants to finish
scalebound yeah i bet they do
so let let's break this down let's break
this down
first thing i want to talk about
is do you think
that microsoft needs a scale bound these
days we're going to go with hustle and
motivate first
what no
no you got call of duty or what's all
but certain you gotta call it dude no no
no no you don't need it you don't need
it
if if i were them hey yo first of all
they got they got more than enough
studios either way if they really want
to put out scale down they could
actually go do that they could probably
get the coalition to go put off scale
about if we really being real about it
with that unreal engine five can you
imagine how that's gonna look dude you
gotta hey gonna be a passion project for
him yep yep hey man come on man come on
no they don't
not only do they not need it but they
don't need platinum games either but you
know i want to jump ahead i'm i'm i'ma
slow up i'm gonna slow my road just a
little bit i'm gonna hit y'all with some
facts
we're definitely gonna go into like the
actual studio
and whether or not
microsoft should trust them into
investing into another uh shot
at
scale bound so let's go to bitcloud do
you think that microsoft needs scale
bound uh considering they they do are
getting better i do think they still
like that type of games
yeah i mean they got doom they got call
of duty that's really you feel your
recipe right now compared to a scale
about but um if we're talking about
mending a uh i guess um the flame so to
speak people still hold on microsoft for
the whole scale down not working on the
xbox i do think they wanted to make up
for that it would be smart to get them
let them get let them do it but at the
same time is it worth the investment so
to speak you know i mean
it's up in here it's a toss up i mean as
you can flip a coin at it
to be honest and just say like that now
if they gave them unreal engine 5 and
let them
have the tools of the trade i ain't
gonna lie i would be lying to you i
would i would be like i said i wouldn't
be interested in seeing how it will look
you know i mean with that type of uh
approach those assets you you can get
that super chat
uh sifu x initiative
yes you did sir thank you very much um
he said
i'm too old wait hold on hold on
i'm old two bit yeah we all load over
here
i got that
my knees are already starting to jerk
when i walk don't worry about it
when you turn 30 you're going to wake up
it's going to be cold one morning that's
what happened to you it's gonna be cold
one morning you're like yo do i gotta
get out of bed it's gonna hurt don't
worry about it i'm 36 by the way
yeah every day is a struggle so you know
when you know when you know what time
there's not looking at the day
so
back to uh what we were talking about
like
as far as if xbox needs this game i
don't think they do
but i do think
if it was done right
it would help their portfolio
especially give them more of like a
japanese uh
style games because they they do that
well i do believe we are the only
console owner
console manufacturer that haven't had a
platinum games exclusive
uh so you know
if they can make a scale bound that is
the quality of the other stuff they've
made for playstation the stuff they made
for the nintendo switch
i feel like it would be worth the
investment now now let's go into if
microsoft
should trust
platinum games into making this because
this is a big thing like
if you guys remember correctly it was it
was bad when this got canceled
like
were you keeping up with this stuff back
then hustle
did you remember the gameplay reveal
well oh yeah you mean that you played
reveal
well like it was showing the dragon and
it was it was running out like they were
all freaking too francis yeah
it was it was so bad seven frames yeah
it was it was it ran pretty bad um
the most the thing that i kept up with
it was i remember
the project got cancelled and i remember
when i got canceled
and
when they tried to blame mike uh
platinum tried to blame microsoft
microsoft was like nah that wasn't us
that was y'all i know it was y'all and
then later on um platinum had came out
against the former ceo he must he came
out with an apology was like yo we
laughed up that was all bad um and when
i remember seeing that
and even now like when we saw that when
i saw that news article today you know
i'm at it when you sent it to me
via ign
um shout out to oh my god he's in there
he's in the she was one of the first
people in the chat he had dropped oh my
god i'm sorry for not getting your
credit bruh you know who you are um i
think it was no brad bingham it was brad
bring him in the chat was like yo yeah
hustle the ceo left like three weeks ago
and that's why all these talks are
coming up again so i went looked it up
as you know did my due diligence
and bret bingham was 100 right so
if
if that's anything to go by it sounds
like there was a real issue at the top
at the top top the way it was like now
we won't want no pause to this and now
that you know that gentleman's gone and
you know what
i'm i might kill him
saying it yeah there we go
until she uh
and oh my god hold on hold on i'm gonna
put this name in the chat damn that
i'll put this name in the chat wait you
ain't gonna get me like that you ain't
getting me this guy right here i saw who
it is
look at the chat you see my you see my
little thing um
that's
pause
new ceo
that's the new ceo he wants to take it
back overseas
yes and you you know
you know what it could be this
individual probably saw what happened
back then and it always made him feel
way you know what i'm saying where
because like look microsoft got a lot of
the heat for this
but i'm sure industry wise like on the
on the the publisher side
all the blame internally was always put
on pla was platinum games and i'm sure
there was a lot of publishers that saw
something like this it was like not
necessarily they won't work with them
but it was like we're gonna have to be
really
cautious when we work with platinum
games and i'm willing to let that happen
for a while they might still be getting
some backlash for what that happened
because in the actual statements he said
he apologized
to the fans into microsoft because they
trusted them as a partner
and
he seemed like he just wanted to correct
the mistake like
yeah
but but platinum um i did a platinum i
did some research on platinum anyway
don't they work on like multiple games
at once and i don't know how big their
studio is but they're they have a
reputation for doing stuff like that
like you know if i think if platinum
slowed down we'll get more titles like a
bayonetta you know regardless of what
people may think about bayonetta i feel
like the only
[Music]
i feel like the only way that platinum
is going to slow down is if someone buys
them and gives them
uh
income where they because one of the
reasons that they do what they do is
because it's the only way to keep the
lights on like they have to take
multiple projects to get multiple sets
of income to feed it into
work because usually they they'll take
on multiple incomes and they'll feed it
into one game and sell that game
and you know i get it we got a five
dollar super chat from uh from the
doctor 63. devil may cry plus panda
dragoon
just won
well cognito's not here
so uh
[Laughter]
you know definitely feel free
see i've never played panzer dragon
dragoon or whatever it's called i've
never i'm going to be wrong with you i i
think you'll like it
i'm i'm the the no cap i really think
you will like it for real it's not um
it's a flying third-person game i think
you'll like it for real somebody i think
you'll enjoy all right so big cloud
do you think that microsoft should
invest and trust platinum games if they
were actually entertaining this would
you personally let that trust and
investment go out
i mean if they're owned by microsoft
that means microsoft has the final say
in terms of how they go about it right
no i'm not talking about buying i'm
talking about just making scalebound
i'll just make a scale mount
you know
it's it's tough man because their track
record is not over the top i mean look
at bayonetta on the switch forgot to
even i blame the switch for that
i'm just personally i would say you know
if they wanted to like i say remove the
stain
from their shirts which is scalebound
being canceled on the xbox i mean
because a lot of people still hold that
against them to this day if they wanted
to mend that and make up for type of
thing and be like yo this is our apology
and let them make the right game now
they have a more accessible console sure
if they wanted to do that the question
is how much is that project you know i
mean is it worth the investment and
personally it comes down to them they
have to make it worth that investment
they have to show off you know i mean
that it's worth
so it's worth it because the first game
play we saw yeah i remember it was again
it was only got three frames it was
really bad everybody was going always
just the video i remember david showed
that they were like always the video or
the stream was like i'm like no that's
not extreme
that bad so
they definitely if they want to make
something ambitious you got to make sure
you show
your your um your improvement since then
you said i'm going like your direction
since then have you improved since we
first ever saw scale down and then i'll
say yeah it's worth investing in and
doing that so okay here here's my
standpoint
um
i think microsoft should invest into it
if it is an option and phil spencer is
interested i do think it needs to be
monitored heavenly
uh until because at the end of the day
like if someone robs you you don't just
actively give them money later like
you're like you know someone owed you
money and they didn't give you money but
you dumb enough to give them money again
this time you're probably going to send
a bouncer over there to collect your
money
so you know
that's my standpoint on that now
hear me out guys imagine an e3 moment
because we don't know if e3 is coming
back where that they got that digital
event and they say we got one more game
for you and then they they do this
this clever marketing where they don't
tell you the game
but at the end
it shows that
devil may cry dante looking character
whatever his name was and he showed up
on stage on on the video and he was and
his dragon showed up behind him right
breathed in front of him and it said
scale bound coming out in 2023
would that set the internet on fire
yeah it was a stealth announcement yeah
everybody just showed like the banner
yeah yeah that would be fire they did
that with the order 18 out like that
right there would be like a might drive
more for a lot of people just like if
sony was to go uh with the order too you
know i mean like it would be like a
banner they're not the show
or nothing gameplay like by the way guys
we have a very special announcement he
walks away better gets showed and then
the team comes out and talks about the
project so yeah i agree
underrated oh the order 1886 hello
underrated i know a lot of people don't
like it because of the quick they make
it they really don't like it because of
the quick time um cut scenes in that
game yeah like the league ball though
it's like yeah yeah like they joined
cool they joined that was cool to me i'm
at the part where um you came up with
the spoiler i'm at the part where you
team up with the indian girl when um
something's amiss or something so yeah
you find out yeah you be you beat it
right you beat me like no yeah no yeah
you'd be doing it no i played it and
i'll put it down
what what i want to bring up when it
come to scale bound and i see a lot of
people in the chat saying it's past when
you leave in the past i agree with you
this game could easily stay in the past
it wouldn't bother me but we got 230
people in the chat man hit that like
button let's get that over a hundred
likes before the end of this week hold
on before before we even go on shout out
to hip hop game in the chat hey you you
might be on to something when it comes
to their playstation backwards
compatibility sir
i'm just saying you might be onto
something man
oh here you know
you know your brother
you know what you just said hip-hop you
should have tagged we're not tagged
let's not be that messy but you should
have put a post on twitter that said
when you guys write about this when he
gets announced just make sure you spell
my name right
[Laughter]
for sure sir i told i've been telling
people that like a lot of stuff that
hip-hop standby is a long-term goal for
playstation
yeah
and they better get on it yeah it's a
long-term goal it's not something that's
going to drop in one pack just something
they have to build for it's why they're
doing all this stuff and changing uh the
format and whatnot now they're fixing
something that's we've been asking for
for the longest and that is multiplayer
games we need those on playstation
side note before we move on i'm getting
the ogp i'm getting the um the george
foreman grill ps3 so i can play ps1
there
no no sorry i'm i'm definitely about to
go away i like retro stuff i missed a
lot of luck
i stopped questioning him a long time
ago big cloud no well what i when he
said that i just thought about mystic
when he made the day of console into a
legit grill like he bought like oh
on the ps3 put the george girl in there
and made it i'm like that's a shame
but i'm totally i'm definitely coming
what's up let me finish that statement
real quick like when it comes to why i
think this would be a big deal it's not
necessarily about completing anything
that they need
because i don't think they need
scalebound it's not about completing
something that
that they want because i don't think
they necessarily want scalebound i think
it's about correcting the past
and i think it's about
moving on with that scenario like big
cloud it's been what five six years
since that all that happened and they
still asked phil spencer almost yearly
at least two or three people what
happened with scalebound although using
the argument like well oh yeah microsoft
is so trustworthy does y'all forget
about scalebound it's okay how about we
take that from them we bring you know we
give them that shot we get in that
redemption game and they become this
passion right because they can't say
nothing if it's a if it's legit what
they envision it to be all those years
ago and when it delivers and it's fire i
mean hell nobody can say nothing and i i
just feel like
pr wise
coming out with scale bound
would be i think there's there's two
games that microsoft can hit
rice on a rope sql and scale bounce if
any of those showed up on a stage
you're the internet's gonna catch on
fire the media is going to gravitate so
hardcore to microsoft it's unreal i
could just see
the
the title lines now microsoft revives
fan favorite
or microsoft does this like how
when is the last time you guys heard of
a game getting cancelled and being
brought back six seven years later
like it doesn't happen often i mean you
know phil spencer was just in the
interview i forget with whom but after
the activision deal he was like yeah we
trying to bring back guitar hero and as
well as a couple of other old favorites
so if you bring that guitar hero bring
back dj hero that's why
but you know it's just the thing if they
want to go back and dig in the crates so
to speak and do that um like i said
again they don't need platinum games to
make that game and if i were microsoft
even though they don't need it if i were
them i would have it
i would have something like that in the
tuck anyway just to be like now we got a
new thing over here that's kind of like
a panzer dragon type thing or whatever i
would do it just for the versatility of
what you had but i will say that it does
look like microsoft's been real
comfortable here lately with hiring
third-party developers making games like
it i've i'm very confident that
capcom is making a killer instinct
um i don't know when it will come out
wait
hold on capcom
yes i'm pretty sure it's capcom
the capcom who who who had um street
fighter 5 exclusive to playstation i
know playstation is only funded i think
look at the end of the day okay that's
what's going around the twitter streets
you can watch multiple podcasts hearing
that all right but
if they might
i personally don't feel like capcom is
the right move but if that is the
direction that they're going
i personally feel like
they should have bought a studio just
one studio from someone that makes
head-to-head fighters and say we want
you to make hillary instinct and i think
that would have worked out so well i i
honestly feel like too that one of the
biggest
issues that they're having is they got
some of these namco that's who it is
and i honestly feel like
the people who make guilty gear
i don't know who they are they're like
some a name some a
name um i'm pretty sure the chat is
going to correct me that's what the chat
does
so
that's on the tip of my tongue
i feel like
that studio could make a great killer
instinct it's similar graphics
and
i just want
i'm one of those people
that i'm selfish in my own ways but i
still want everybody to eat it's just i
want to eat first
so you know
i would appreciate that's why the wb
studios meant so much to me
because
i would have wanted them to pick up that
over something arc systems yes systems i
would have preferred someone pick up
well then pick up wb games over
something like like activision sure
activision makes the most sense
industry-wise because they have those
yearly thing but to me when it comes to
portfolio and what microsoft is missing
i felt like wb games made the most sense
because they would have superhero
rocksteady steady to to make their
superhero games they could literally go
to anyone they wanted to and with 60
billion dollars they bought wb they
could have probably bought batman's low
damn licensing for that much money
well i thought it wasn't enough for sale
though i thought well you know
no they bid for it they bid for it but
they but they decided if microsoft would
have dropped dropped the kind of the
kind of energy they dropped into
activision they would own wb right now
and it's like no
they would they would have got
netherrealm from wb and another and they
would have got more to the mortal kombat
license because that they did confirm
that was coming with the uh the cell
and imagine if the first game they put
out there was mortal kombat versus
killer instinct
yeah well
i'm i'm here i'm here for the versus
games you know the wall parts
i don't think they care as much about
fighters even though they got some games
i don't think they carry do you think i
said because evil yeah that's awesome do
you think it's because
yeah sony's put more effort into
fighting games they got this new pattern
going around where you can bet on your
favorite fighters stuff like that
they're trying to build you can hype
basically you be hypeman in the crowd
that's how the patents were you can go
i'm teaming this guy and throw money
like oh my bids this that the third type
of thing so that's why i think um with
the acquisitions going around i think
it's probably more likely to be capcom
for sony just so they get street fighter
i don't know
by the way go ahead and continue big
club somebody they're going somebody can
get their pete rose on and go ahead
but i think capcom is the next one for
them
hands down since it's going around that
um
something about japanese uh acquisitions
microsoft can't do or something like
that i read or something like that you
forgot what it was i saw it recently so
i think in order for microsoft to even
acquire a company in japan they have to
own right right in japan
studios
oh well you go there i don't know i
still need to get i need to get hogan
here and ask him how these things work
i'm gonna reach out to him in the next
couple weeks to come on here yeah
because i i'm still
i've been told on the back end
that there is
don't believe that like it's technically
there but what i've been told is you
could easily
find your ways around that that law like
and i think a lot of has to do with like
japan themselves invest into some of
these companies but i know they don't do
it with everyone because i don't think
they do it with sony anymore
uh i i think that when it comes to a
certain point like i don't know if so if
sony doesn't want them doing it or maybe
the japan government pulled out for
their own reasons you know what i'm
saying i don't know exactly what's going
on there i'm not over there i'm just
telling you what like i see on the
internet and stuff
sound note real quick um apparently
someone in saudi arabia i don't know if
it's like a prince or yeah god invested
into it
okay
pretty much everybody like a lot of
black
especially peop because you know capcom
got something so hitters
but boy don't they they got to do this
and we don't see them
here
here is this one
do you think maybe they're making uh
that
platinum games is making this type of
public statement because this is a big
public statement to literally come out
there and say it was our fault we the
one that cheated we the ones that spent
the life savings like
we did all of this wrong you think they
might be trying to like mend that fence
a little bit to be like yo let's work
together a little bit you know maybe you
come in the back
maybe maybe after this game and we prove
ourselves you come in the back door with
the bag and you buy the company like
i mean look at like this you're known
for one of the biggest fails in a long
time next to cyberpunk right you're
known for that your game is known for
that and then you're also known for
being probably the only publisher to
blame
for your mistakes you know the
publisher's idea or the publisher's
responsibility is to advertise said game
that's about it it's your job to make
sure it works because it's your game
well i mean
we can't say that a hundred percent
because i do know that microsoft
did seem like they were pushing like a
co-op experience into the game so you
know
because if you look at that article they
do bring up in the article that that was
one of the reasons they're having such a
hard time because they're not used to
working with those kind of systems
but it's just like at the end of the day
you're still a developer that's why i
talk about diversity like when it comes
to making sure developers are diverse in
the in the type of games they make
because there's certain studios like
the people who make
horizon zero dawn uh guerilla games
they were making a first person shooter
before that so they diversed that all
the way over there and i'm not saying
that
it wasn't because they didn't hire
talent that was working with those type
of games but my question is why didn't
platinum hire talent that was working
with those type of games
or at least contractors that have
experience in multiple experience games
they didn't do none of that and i can't
say that it's it's in a bad thing or
anything like that i can't say anything
i don't know what happened all i do know
is that all of a sudden
it seems like platinum games is
interested in making skill bound out of
nowhere sure they came out openly said
that they would like to but they've
never been this vocal
and
i personally feel like
in the mind in the back of their mind yo
if we come out there and we do our best
and we give them a game that's game of
the year material
they might buy us out and we can stop
with these eight game rotations like
so saying you never bite the hand that
feeds you though see because now they
gotta heal the hand they gotta do that
like they're gonna do that far cry thing
where they ripping the bullet out and
then they gotta like nurture the hand
back to health like
now they're going up they're going out
like ethan um what's that resident evil
7.
yeah it's over it's almost losing limbs
and then putting back yeah
we got you can't i don't think you could
piece this one back together though
though i i don't think cause like
like for all intents and purposes
they're not needed like honestly they
are they aren't needed like we're being
wrong with all the with the spree that
they're microsoft they're like 30 plus
studios like yo if somebody wants to
make scale bound or remake it or make it
the thing is though is like nintendo
buys them well how'd you guys feel about
that
i think that would make a better sense
like
yeah because they stay working with them
like that yeah that makes more sense but
like it's not they can't buy the ip but
with nintendo on microsoft buddy buddy
phil might just be like hey i throw you
a little bone or whatever like he hey he
might do that he very well may do that
but i just wouldn't be tripping off that
i just feel like it's not necessary to
get scalebound
but man if that game came out and it was
imagine big cloud and one e3 they
announced uh
rice center room two in scale bound in
the same conference yeah he just said
hey guys at one point we made a mistake
we just fixed it yeah phil was like yeah
we made a mistake in the past and we
want to make it right i'm very happy to
announce or make these two announcements
that you see them back to back to scale
and then it says rise to the world goes
crazy and if you think about it
if you think about it they already
brought fable back
so they corrected that
that would be the last two that would
kind of like
it would really it would it would it
would be one of those things where
it's like we have openly admitted that
both parties have done wrong in the past
but we're here to fix it and i i think
it would give them a lot
of pr
extremely positive pr
i think all you would see is microsoft's
for the players microsoft's for the
developers microsoft gives second
chances like this
before we before we move on before we
end where did y'all hear this uh bandai
namco aroma that they're doing keller
instinct i know you said it was in
twitter spaces or podcasts i figured you
was joking around but is there like some
type of like valid source that i can
take a look at because that
that to me would be a little different
because it's just
who don't know
one of my favorite games on nintendo
switch was made by bandai namco that's
super smash brothers
game the game super fire at this point
at this point
at this point microsoft needs to make a
studio
and hire
nothing but x super smash brother devs
and make a super smash brothers for the
play xbox and because at this point they
have banjo kazooie they have the doom
slayer they have halo they have arbiter
they have all the people from gears all
the people from sea of thieves they have
so many iconic franchises they have
spyro no i don't want the new r stars
let's
let's
no
that's why i said
that's why i said that you hire
the people that made the real goat which
is super smash brothers and i honestly
think that
you get that
you get
they're going to be fine if they don't
do [ __ ] we're saying let's be real here
uh apparently jess corden said it
somewhere i'm not we're not going out
there and putting misinformation the
chat says chess gordon so we're going to
that's what y'all that that's what the
chat said you could take that how you
will but i just
i would like a scale bound not for me
personally
just to show
that microsoft is trying to correct
past mistakes and that would be really
nice because you got it with fable
but i do feel like scalebound was that
one time in the xbox history
where i felt the hate
like i i generally it was bad hustle
it was bad
i was youtubing back then
it was bad but anyway what do you guys
got anything else to say about this
platinum games wants to make scale bell
well
in closing it sounds like the full the
former ceo said something
or probably did something he shouldn't
have did and now that he's out
it's uh hey
can we can we get back good again and
they you know mike phil microsoft they
might say you know what come on let's
get back good again they don't need to
again i'll stand on i'm gonna stand on
that one and say they don't need to but
they probably look you know they
probably just haven't saw something else
but you know um piece of advice for
platinum though they
because they got a lot of good games
like neil i saw neil aldamado on that
list and they got like bayonetta they
got good stuff over there i would just
say
try to work on stuff one at a time and i
know attitude said something earlier
about are they trying to get it quiet
i mean you know if i if i had the brand
honestly i probably would pick them up
like i said
or something yeah just just forget
confirm hustle is in talk to platinum
games right now to pick them up oh man
hey almost cursed oh here oh man yeah i
wish i wish i had the money to do so
they'd be working on one thing at a time
it'd be a masterpiece i'll tell you
everything would be quality
will you students i don't care
slow down i will say this though it
seems like a lot of these ceos though
low-key are like the cause of a lot of
um
stuff especially morale like i know it's
like the morale seems to gone up
after this acquisition news i mean like
everybody's excited for it and that's a
brighter future that could lead to
better games you know a better focus on
quality
so obviously quant uh platinum games you
know the ceo leaving i don't know attic
there is possibly you know there's a
possibility of a of a light you know i
mean then the tunnel type of thing where
they can give you
lightning in a bottle type of thing if
it's done right and see i i think i'm
more on that microsoft's done so well
with giving us
i uh you know studios that's promising
to bring us good ips in the future
i'm at this point where i want them to
hit us with shock value
yeah like you know activision i felt
like i don't know about you guys but i
felt like bethesda hit me more than
activision did and maybe it's because
maybe it's because bethesda was the
first real big purchase like that and
activision when i heard it i was like
well that makes sense they got the money
i didn't think it was possible until
bethesda but when they bought bethesda
i generally did not expect that like
because they bought bethesda i think it
made me accept that they could buy
another big publisher if that makes
sense
but when they bought bethesda i ain't
even i was like oh my god that's
literally what i did like this like
but anyway what do you guys got going on
with you guys what what you got going on
hustle i know you got something
yeah well you know working behind the
scenes like the new stream set up um as
y'all can tell i was kind of
experimenting with a few different
lights but
be back on twitch hopefully
next week hopefully like next friday
i'll be able to kick everything back off
i'm gonna have to get a few things in
order first but twitch.tv hustle and
motivate same thing with twitter you
follow me there too but um i'm gonna
finish uncharted and then i'm gonna take
a i'm gonna take a little break i'm
gonna take a little break because i
wanna i wanna take y'all back let's see
hustle how far you wanna go back i'm
gonna go way back i'm gonna go way back
too
how about you finish the order first
then you go back to them you know what i
should you know that secret
you know what you could play hustlers
you could play that game
please
play
oh we definitely passing on both of
those
things i promise you that this seafood
looks cool [ __ ] shaq fool man he shacked
who had the cover
look
at that he had the cover he's like
shocked fool too for those of you all
who don't know how did that
big cloud game what you got going on for
you man
uh you already know man friday's rgt
podcast 5 p.m est guys want to
check us out it's on the channel big
cloud gaming um all my work for ign
should be hopefully posted this month so
i'm
just showing right now let's go get it
getting hyped uh because i'm waiting for
the okay i don't know if i'm going to
cover eldon ring or
horizon or what i don't know i'm waiting
otherwise i'm married i have to buy
these games i just reached out i didn't
even buy shifa i was gonna go home are
they gonna
call me for this and i was like uh and
actually there's one guy i'm like you
lucky pastor so some dudes are
dudes on the list got certain games but
we'll we'll see if i if i get it and if
i get it then uh i'll obviously start my
cover but yeah
that's what i've been doing you know and
i definitely appreciate everyone coming
out we add up to like 240 50 people in
here you know that was definitely
growing it's like i said i i do know
that all of this looks basic
can we as hell
more like to hit 100 please can we get
what two more likes to hit 100 please
we're at 98
uh hustlers ocd is going to going to get
him so i'm gonna go for hustle's mental
health
hit that like button for hustles what's
going on with this uh feel the glow type
of mentality i've been seeing now with
uh adam you know what it says like feel
the glow i'm gonna glow this glowing
down from the layout what's going on
i just want to look no screen on
look
i want to look
presentable all right like all these
black bars this this ain't it like this
the same hat
so i'm a i'm a reach out we're going to
get this to take care of i'm a i'm a
really look into well you know king
wants me to do an intro and stuff like
we have on iop that's coming later
that's not my priority my partner you
my priority is making sure
the podcast looks good then we'll move
on to the intro and stuff like that
we'll move on to that then but i
appreciate it everyone coming through
man we're gonna go ahead and close this
out of here and until next time and next
week i'll probably try to get maddie
play on i'm gonna try it just depends